after the pretty spectacular entrance
you made at the end of fast and furious
6 what was it like stepping in and being
able to fully flesh out Shaw in seven
the way you have
you know it's uh it's a great
opportunity you know they got a terrific
director James Wan is a super smart very
very passionate filmmaker loves what he
does and he was he he was show excited
when he told me about the opening he was
like listen Jason I got this thing and
he stood by the hospital man and you're
gonna and he literally painted the
picture and I was like I love it I love
it like I don't care if that's the only
scene I do and uh so you know it's great
we've got a great filmmaker to be at the
helm and you know his movies are
brilliant and he knows what he's doing
so you already you know that he's gonna
he's gonna do you something do some
justice to the to the to the movie yeah
well like you said this man knows how to
make an entrance shot
what do you think separates him from
other antagonists that the team have
come across
like I don't know what separates it
mother knows everyone's got their own
issues you know it's there's a man who's
you know driven blight driven by you
know blood is thicker than water you
know it you're gonna do this to my
family you know I'm going to show you
what family really means this is what
you stand for well guess what there's
another one over here
so you know there's some real I think
there's a respect that sort of goes on
between the two because the end of the
day it's that's what you stand for guess
what I stand for the same thing but
we're going to bang heads and that's the
way it's going to be so I like that
element I really do
Robert and plain you know a silly bad
guy that comes in trying to you know do
indiscriminate damage to a load of
bystanders and you know try and Rob
everybody of their money and do stupid
bad guy things changes everything when
it's personal no yeah I think so but you
know it's it's not new it's not fresh
but it's real you know personal is
personal and people relate to that all
the time
in a and it's understand it after your
little event at the hospital then
big action moment is the fight with
Hobbs
moms in shock yeah can you talk a little
bit about what you wanted to bring to
that fight
is not a guy that you can take down so
easily it's better an understatement
yeah I mean he's a he's a he's a monster
of a man and you stand in front of him
and you just go Jesus thank god this is
a movie I mean he is a colossal you know
mountain of muscle and you know to be
able to to fight that with you know slug
for slug ain't gonna work so you know
there's a action choreographer that has
a style that he wants to put in and you
have to work with that and you know the
style was quicker fastest moving at a
different pace to try and get through
the through the brute force and
traveling through the office you're not
fighting in one place you're moving all
the way through doors and windows and
floors yeah tables yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's couch is what I remember when
you have as many fights as you and Duane
have collective
on screen is there a bit of a shorthand
totally you've got the nail on the head
yeah you just know what's coming yet you
can you can sort of a cut and paste
things take things out you can put that
move in there it's all a bit of a you
know what feels right for you it's easy
to to change things because it has to
feel right and uh you know experience
there's no substitute for that and after
that there's no question
the audience mine that Shaw means
business
than what that sha means business after
he yeah you put that you put hubs in
hospital what are you gonna do haha I'm
sure no I'm good to ever do that yeah um
just shot even though his only goal is
to take them down
does he develop a grudging respect for
this team and what they are able to do
of course yeah because you have to do
that's what they stand for and they are
pretty damn good at what they do the
third act finale the face-off between
Sean and Dom on the rooftop yeah they
both choose to put down their weapons
they both could have ended this in a
very different way that they choose not
to but
well you know I think the old-fashioned
ways the best way you know weapons
aren't really a great thing they are if
you're on the losing side but if it's
just you know it's just what we call a
straightener it's let's do this
man-to-man and I think every person out
there can only respect people that fight
fairly and there's nothing fairer than
the old fisticuffs so that's the way
that happens you've been a part of the
event film
plenty of the vent filled
in your career so far but the
anticipation and the excitement globally
for
unbelievable no yeah yeah I mean it's
I've never been a part of anything like
this because it's so big and it's so you
know people are just chomping at the bit
to uh you know to get in the cinemas and
see it and uh yeah I mean it's got so
many so many elements that are causing
you know the the attraction
you